what's up guys today we'll be developing
the mood board and material palette for
my filming room which I'm trying to turn
into a slightly more livable space
because right now it's a complete
disaster if you haven't watched the last
video where I developed the functional
layout for the space you can check it
out right here a portion of this video
is sponsored by Wayfair more on their
Awesome YouTube series later in this
video sometimes Architects really really
drill down on the functional aspects and
they skip this step altogether which is
why some architect design interior
spaces can feel really cold and
impersonal and actually I only learned
how to create a proper mood board during
my time when I was working with a lot of
interior designers but I would say this
is such an important process because you
can really narrow down on the material
and color palette and you can also
really learn a lot about your clients
and all of their hopes and dreams and
their weird desires
and
if you're doing it for yourself it can
really help you learn more about
yourself and what you're drawn to
because a lot of the times we just go
through our life saying oh I like this I
like this but we don't really fully
understand why so all in all a mood
board is really important in creating a
space that's yours and something that
reflects who you are so the very first
thing that I do is I just start coming
up with some words that describe the
mood that I'm trying to achieve the
interior designers that I worked with
they went Way Beyond and they created
like entire poems but I like to keep it
pretty nice and concise like six to nine
words mine were relaxing warm inviting
kind cozy uplifting and happy once I've
got these descriptive words I I start
scrounging through Pinterest to see
which images I'm drawn to they can be
images of Design Elements but not
necessarily they can be scenes from
nature or anything that evokes those
emotions that you're trying to create at
first don't be too precious with images
and just try to save all the images that
align with your words but as you're
doing this be mindful of your existing
conditions for example if you have any
signature architectural elements or
Furniture pieces that you want to keep
look for images that have that for
example I have a space with a fairly low
ceiling and little daylight so although
I'm really drawn to these dark and Moody
spaces I know it's going to be really
difficult to achieve because it is going
to feel very dark and very crammed I
also have this red brick which honestly
right now I'm going back and forth about
whitewashing is my red brick background
getting a little stale I don't know
are you guys sick of this
but if I do it there's no turning back
so let me know in the comments if I
should do this or not but anyways yes I
do have this right now and I do love
these warmer tones and it just reminds
me of autumn which is like my favorite
season so I'm pulling out a lot of
images with these warm red and orange
and brown tones I also know exactly what
flooring I want to use it's the Wickford
Oak vinyl plank flooring which I have in
my office and it's one of the few vinyl
plank products that really look and feel
like wood and obviously I would love to
use real wood but a vinyl is much more
affordable it's easier to install and
it's incredibly durable and it's
waterproof and since this is just my
filming room I am just gonna go with a
vinyl product so just based on these
parameters I already have my base color
palette and and so I'm pulling out a lot
of images that have elements of this to
get inspiration for complementary tones
and materials a quick message from
today's sponsor Wayfair
you guys probably know a Wayfarer as a
place where you can get Chic affordable
home product but you might not know
about their Awesome YouTube channel
they've got this cool new series called
interior motives where they try to solve
very specific design problems for
example having a really messy camera
setup like a certain somebody they might
bring in a professional videographer or
on this episode they're bringing in a
baker for tips on laying out a kitchen a
lot of times we design spaces based on
inspiration photos that we find on
Pinterest or on Instagram but to make
that space really functional and to make
it work for you we really need that
lived in experience of someone who uses
that space a lot especially when it
comes to knowing what storage to get
even if you're just trying to make your
space a little bit nicer or a little bit
more functional I think this series is
going to give you a lot of practical
tips and a lot of things to consider
anyways go check out their episode on
kitchen designs is really well produced
it's really well researched and it's
really fun to watch and go subscribe to
their channel it's full of really great
content I'll include the link in the
description so once you've got your
images you can start the selection
process but just be careful because with
Pinterest or Instagram it's really easy
to buy into a look but these images
are heavily fabricated and a lot of
times heavily photoshopped and it's
taken in a very specific spatial
condition so it can be really deceiving
because even if you copy exactly what's
in the image it's never going to look
the same in your space so when you're
narrowing down your selection try to
identify by what it is about the image
that you like for me I really love the
light neutral Mediterranean colors but
in this image I love how this darker
Walnut tone just makes it feel a little
bit more modern and sophisticated I'm
also really feeling these black details
because I think it just really elevates
the natural scheme here I really love
the combination of the fabric this color
glass Foss which again is a really nice
contrast but also adds something warm
and it also feels more contemporary and
elevated one thing to note I think a lot
of people feel like you need to get all
the pieces that are in the same style
category but you don't really need to as
long as they're in complementary color
tones don't be afraid of mixing and
matching especially if you're someone
who likes thrifting and having objects
that have like a story behind them the
this is going to add personality to your
space if you're having a hard time
understanding what you like a really
good reference can be your closet what
are the clothes that make you happy for
me my closet has a lot of black
red orange and neutrals lo and behold
those are the colors that I'm really
drawn to so try to see if there's any
color themes or textures or ideas that
you can pull from your closet if you see
a pattern then that's a pretty good
jumping off point because those are the
colors that you're going to feel good in
and of course you have your lived in
experience even though I love this
earthy texture I don't find them
comfortable for long periods like I had
these really soft pillows and I'd always
get compliments from people saying oh my
God this pillow is so nice and they'd
always hog the pillows and that
experiential quality is really important
for me so even if I like the look of
something I'd prefer to prioritize the
function so now that I've narrowed down
my mood board and I know what color
tones I want to use I gather the
physical material board I've got my own
material library at home but you can
also order samples from the manufacturer
or my go-to source is material Bank in
my last video I showed you how I
developed elevations by doing some quick
sketches and I was really focusing on
creating order in the space because it's
really kind of fragmented I did that by
creating a datum line along here and I
also wanted to create some height
because we have a very low ceiling
height so I did that by placing low
Furniture to bring the sight line down
and by adding tall curtains and Tall
wall art to elongate the space Also I
created two zones they're connected but
distinct zones one for filming and one
for lounging from that I made a rough
SketchUp model with some generic
SketchUp Furniture now I'm going to take
this model and I'm gonna set up some
views and print out some perspectives
and go back to procreate to start
playing around with the color
combinations at this point I'm
definitely starting to look at stores
and also Facebook Marketplace I love
Marketplace and I'm just trying to see
what's out there but if you start doing
this too early you can kind of go crazy
with all the millions of options out
there and you can kind of risk buying
things that don't really go together so
I like to narrow this down before I
start shopping I just set up my drawings
the same way I've done with the rough
sketches but this time I'm being a
little bit more careful with my lines
because you're using this to get buy-in
from the client I draw all of my lines
on the base layer and I create another
layer for the color options now when
you're trying out different color
combinations you should try to keep
those initial goals in my case order
height and zones and just like the
initial sketching phase you can color
them in really roughly and do a couple
of different options and see which one
you want to develop more in detail I
also hate bright lighting so most of my
lights are going to come from spotlights
so I create another layer on top with a
dark color wash and I basically start
coloring in where I want the lights to
go this gives you a much better sense of
how your lighting is going to work by
the way if you're interested in my
procreate brush pack I've everything
from pens to markers to brushes as well
as people Silhouettes that I use on a
daily basis I'll leave that in the
description of this video so in the end
I want to go with this very simple
neutral option I'm going to add the
accent with the cushions and Furniture
pieces in the next video I'm going to go
through the full renovation but if you
have any questions on any of this just
let me know in the comments and if you
haven't watched the previous video I'll
leave it right here and with that I'll
see you guys in the next video bye
foreign
[Music]